[Music]
I think what keeps people from talking
is being embarrassed of how you're
feeling thinking that no one will
understand hi I'm Louise and this is my
story
[Music]
before I watched 13 reasons why I barely
told anything about myself like I don't
want to be known as the girl that got
raped I just want to be known as Louise
I was scared to talk about it I felt
like no one understood what I was going
through because like no one's ever told
me that they've been through the same
thing it was it was really tough I broke
down I stopped being so social like you
it really affected me
[Music]
[Laughter]
I related the most of Jessica's
situation in particular because that's
pretty much exactly what happened to me
once I saw that scene I was like wow
this is actually how it feels after
watching that last episode I realized
that I should talk about what happened
to me just so people don't think they're
alone
[Music]
I actually called my sister and was like
hey I have this video I should put it up
but I'm really really scared but it did
help a lot of people so I'm glad I did
so if you don't know my story I am a
rape victim survivor whatever you want
to call me and there's not a day in my
life that it doesn't affect just talking
about it that alone lifted a weight off
my chest now I see myself as you went
through something horrible and you came
out on the other side okay so I'm so
proud people even DM me saying hey I've
been through the same exact thing I'm so
glad you told me about it I feel
comfortable talking about it because you
did to the whole world now they they
have someone to talk to like they can
talk to me
it's okay if you're not ready some
people it's just not their time yet but
when you are ready takes one person to
tell and you'll be okay maybe if it's
it's a professional a parent a best
friend a sibling whatever tell someone
because it makes a huge difference until
get through it I have
[Music]
I didn't tell my family or my friends or
my teachers and I kept it to myself
because I thought it was my own problem
[Music]
I'm Riley and this is my story
[Music]
I am a freshman at Grand Valley State
University I'm passionate about music
and helping other people going
throughout high school I was dealing
with this very abusive and toxic
relationship being belittled and
threatened by the person I trusted most
in my life and I didn't want to live for
a good portion of my life I didn't tell
anyone I didn't tell my family or my
friends or my teachers and I kept it to
myself because I thought it was my own
problem
[Music]
[Laughter]
when I first watched 13 years and why I
struggled with a lot of things that
Hanna Baker went through within the show
so I found a lot of relevance
or Dean of Students came to us with this
idea for 13 reasons why not for 13
consecutive days one person from our
school would come over the loudspeaker
and share a story of emotional
vulnerability of a time they did not
feel good enough as soon as my tape Erin
I had people coming up to me in the
hallway to share their own stories a
girl who have been abused since
elementary school came to the office to
finally get help then we just saw the
progression of compassion we saw flowers
being left in classrooms and in
bathrooms notes on walls saying you are
loved you're beautiful you're strong
there's a reason you are here I did a
lot of healing from this project since
my tape first aired and I still struggle
sometimes with the things that I've
dealt with but now I know that there's
resources and I know there's people who
I can turn to and I've built a support
system that I can go to if I'm having
one of those hard days
[Music]
finding one single person that you can
at least tell your story to gives you
power within yourself to finally say
this is ok and it gives other people
power who are listening to you there is
a lot of healing through sharing your
story with others
[Music]
you
you